les ontariens ont un choix à faire lors
des élections justin trudeau a voté aux
élections ontariennes et son bureau nous
dit qu'il ne votera pas aux prochaines
élections québécoises du 1er octobre
prochain
c'est une décision qui a fait réagir les
conservateurs quand vous représentez des
québécois la chambre des communes mais
que vous votez en ontario je pense que
c'est pas droit dès qu'il habite ottawa
monsieur trudeau qui est un député
fédéral de la région de montréal
aurait-il pu voter au québec
[Musique]
d'abord voici ce que dit la loi lors
d'une élection au québec un québécois
qui a quitté la province depuis plus de
deux ans ne peut pas voter
mais il ya des exceptions le délai de
deux ans ne s'applique pas si une
personne quitte la province pour assumer
des fonctions gouvernementales
en théorie monsieur trudeau aurait donc
pu voter au québec même s'il habite
ottawa depuis 2015
mais en choisissant de voter lors des
élections ontariennes justin trudeau a
renoncé à son droit de vote au québec
l'enjeu ici est une question de
résidente en déposant son bulletin de
vote en ontario le premier ministre fait
de sa résidence de fonction de la rue
sussex sa résidence principale et une
résidence principale
on ne peut pas en avoir deux pour ce qui
est des prochaines élections fédérales
c'est complètement différent monsieur
trudeau pourra voter dans la
circonscription de papineau à montréal
même si sa résidence principale est à
ottawa
un candidat peut voter dans le comté où
il se présente même s'ils n'habitent pas
qu'il n'ya pas de résidence dans cette
circonscription
[Musique]